a line has a slope of seven and goes
through the point negative 4 negative 11
what is the equation of this line in
slope-intercept form so the equation of
any line in slope-intercept form is y is
equal to MX plus b where m is the slope
and b is the y-intercept now in this
problem right here they tell us the
slope they tell us that a line has a
slope of 7 so we know right from the
get-go that M is equal to 7 so we know
the equation of this line in slope
intercept form is going to look like Y
is equal to we know M is 7 so 7 X 7 X
plus let me make that X a little bit
neater 7 X plus plus B and now what we
need to do we need to figure out B and
they give us one more piece of
information they say that the line goes
through the point negative 4 comma
negative 11 so that tells us that when X
is equal to negative 4 then Y is equal
to negative 11 so we can use this
information in what we have or the part
of our equation that would be able to
figure out so far we know that when x is
equal to negative 4 y is going to be
equal to negative 11 so what B what B do
we need to make that happen let's try it
out so Y is negative 11 when X is equal
to negative 4 so negative 11 is equal to
7 times X and in this case X is negative
4 plus B plus plus B and now we can just
solve for B a B that that makes this
equation or that satisfies the
constraint that when X is equal to
negative 4 y is equal to negative 11 so
let's see we get negative 11 is equal to
7 times negative 4 is negative 28 plus B
and now we can add 28 to both sides of
this equation so let's add 28 I'm just
trying to isolate the B on the right
hand
and so on the left-hand side negative 11
plus 28 that is just positive 17 these
guys cancel out on purpose and I just
have a B on the right-hand side so I get
B is equal to 17 let me write it in
green we get that's not green we get B B
is equal to 17 so we now we know M is 7
they told us that right at the beginning
and now we know B is 17 so the equation
of our line is y is equal to 7x that's
our slope 7 times X plus B and B here is
17 and if we wanted to graph it it would
look something like this I'll just do a
real rough graph so if we wanted to
graph this line that's my x-axis and
then this is my y-axis y axis the y
intercept is 17 so that means at the
point 0 17 is on is on this line so this
point right over here is going to be 0
17 and our slope is 7 so that means if
we move to the right one we move up 7 so
it's a high so if we move to the right 1
we move up 7 or if we move back one will
move down 7 so we'll move down 7 so the
line will look roughly like this I
obviously haven't done it very exactly
but our line is going to look like
that's going to be a pretty steep upward
sloping line it has a very high slope
slope of 7 if you move one in the x
direction you have to move up 7 and its
y-intercept is at Y is 17 when x is 0 Y
is 17